Saburō Sakai is perhaps one of the most famous
Japanese air aces to emerge from WWII, credited
with at least 28 aerial victories and shooting
down or severely damaging well over 60 Allied
aircraft, despite later in the war flying
a plane that was vastly inferior to his opponents’
planes.
Saburō Sakai was born one of seven children
in a poor farming family in 1916 just outside
of the city of Saga in Japan.
Despite his limited upbringing, Sakai was
reportedly very studious and was considered
one of the best students at his school; so
much so that his uncle paid for him to come
to Tokyo to study there when he was 12 years
old.
However, despite his best efforts, Sakai was
unable to keep up with his peers in Tokyo
and after two years, his uncle sent him back
home.
It’s stated that on this fateful train journey
home, Sakai saw a poster advertising recruitment
for the Japanese Imperial Navy; two years
later when Sakai turned 16, he enlisted and
began his training.
Sakai quickly rose through the ranks of the
Imperial Navy serving aboard two Japanese
battleships and eventually earning the rank
of Petty Officer Third Class.
In 1937, he applied for pilot training school,
from which he graduated at the top of his
class of 70, of which only 25 managed to successfully
complete the required course of training in
a satisfactory manner.
For his performance, Sakai was given yet another
promotion, this time to the rank of Petty
Officer Second Class and a silver watch, presented
to him personally by the Emperor.
It’s from this point on that Sakai story
gets interesting.
Prior to WWII, Sakai flew several combat missions
during the Second Sino-Japanese War and it’s
noted that during his first ever mission,
he annoyed his commanding officer by using
all of his ammunition to shoot down a single
plane.
Something he made up for a short while later
when the airfield he was stationed at was
bombed by the Chinese in 1939.
According to historical consultant, Mark Barber,
despite being injured by the explosion, Sakai:
“sprinted through burning aircraft to find
an undamaged fighter before taking to the
skies to chase the fleeing bombers.”
Sakai was unable to shoot down the bomber
that had attacked his airfield, but his actions
didn’t go unnoticed by his superiors.
Although they did not give him any sort of
medal for his heroism, a theme that would
be consistent throughout Sakai’s impressive
career, he was promoted to Petty Officer First
Class.
As WWII heated up, Sakai’s skills as a pilot
became more and more apparent and, as mentioned,
he’s credited with downing over 60 Allied
aircraft, including one dogfight in 1942 where
Sakai shot down a confirmed three aircraft
in the span of a mere 15 seconds.
That said, Sakai didn’t always get his target.
For example, in 1942, Sakai tried and failed
to shoot down a B-26 near the coast of New
Guinea.
Why is this significant?
Future U.S. President Lyndon B. Johnson was
aboard that B-26.
Though Sakai was indeed unflinching in his
sense of duty, he was prone to bouts of disobedience
which often bordered on the hilarious.
For example, he would openly smoke comically
huge, illegally obtained cigars in front of
his superiors and once fired his pistol at
the feet of an officer administering a beating
to one of his wingmen.
However, the incident that got Sakai in the
most hot water was when he, along with two
of his wingmen, flew over the Port Moreseby
Airfield in their Zeroes after an aerial skirmish
and did a number of loop the loops just to
annoy the Allies.
A few hours later, a bomber flew over Sakai’s
base and dropped a note thanking the Japanese
for their “wonderful display of acrobatics”
and informing them that the next time they
tried a stunt like that they’d have a “warm
welcome” waiting for them.
Sakai’s most famous exploit came during
that same year when he was shot in the face
by an enemy plane he was in the process of
trying to shoot down.
The shot destroyed the vision in Sakai’s
right eye and crippled the entire left side
of his body.
Disoriented from the wound, Sakai lost control
of his plane which went into a steep dive.
In a stroke of luck, the dive actually ended
up helping him by extinguishing the flames
threatening to consume the cockpit.
Using his one good arm, Sakai was able to
clean away some of the blood from his face
using his fetching silk scarf.
When asked to later recall that day, Sakai
notes that his first thought was that he wanted
to die taking at least one enemy with him
and he immediately began looking for an Allied
ship into which he could crash his damaged
plane.
Despite this, Sakai would later become one
of the most critical opponents of the controversial
Kamikaze technique.
(See: How Were Kamikaze Pilots Chosen?)
In the end, once he found his plane was still
airworthy, he changed his mind and managed
to make it back to base, barely.
What makes this trip back even more remarkable
was that Sakai famously flew almost the entire
1040 kilometre journey back to base UPSIDE
DOWN to stop the blood from his wounds getting
into his good eye and memorably refused medical
treatment until he made his mission report.
Despite losing the sight in his right eye,
he did eventually return to the skies towards
the end of the war and due to his status as
one Japan’s top flying aces, there were
literal fights between younger pilots about
who would be his wingman.
In later interviews, Sakai maintained that
the loss of his eye never affected his flying
ability, something he proved in a dogfight
in 1944 that vaulted him from flying ace,
to legend.
At this time, he was ambushed by no less than
15 Allied Hellcats near Iwo Jima.
In a dogfight that lasted some 20 minutes,
Sakai wasn’t hit by a single enemy round,
despite thousands of rounds being shot at
him and his craft being vastly inferior to
those he was up against at this point in the
war.
In fact, the combination of the Japanese pilots
being largely outnumbered and in outdated
planes near the end of the war resulted in
the Battle of the Philippine Sea in June of
1944 getting nicknamed “The Great Marianas
Turkey Shoot” by the Allies.
Further, two years before this, in June of
1942, Japan lost more airmen in a single day
than they had managed to train in an entire
year just before the war.
This might have you wondering how Sakai survived
the fight.
He simply dodged bullets the best he could
while making sure the battle drifted towards
Iwo Jima, where anti-aircraft guns could do
what he could not in that situation.
It worked and, once in range of the guns,
the Hellcats were driven off.
After the war, Sakai became a Buddhist and
vowed to never harm another living thing.
He also went on to become good friends with
some of the men he’d previously called his
enemy, including Harold Jones, the man who
fired the round that cost him the sight in
his eye, as well as Paul Tibbets, the pilot
of the plane that dropped the atomic bomb
on Hiroshima.
Saburō Sakai died in 2000 at the age of 84
while attending a formal dinner at a U.S.
Navy airbase, in which Sakai was a guest of
honour.
As the New York Times noted shortly after
his death, Sakai “suffered a heart attack
as he leaned across the table to shake hands
with an American; he died later in a hospital.”
The only medal Sakai was ever awarded in his
life actually came from the American military
for defeating two US pilots… in a golf tournament.
Sakai eventually reached the rank of Sub-lieutenant,
making him one of only a handful of Japanese
men to become officers after starting out
as enlisted men.
Ever the rebel, Sakai often kept his lunch
in his standard issue reconnaissance bag in
case he got hungry during flights.
When Sakai learned about the dropping of the
Atomic bomb and Japan’s surrender, he took
to the skies and shot down a B-29 bomber in
retaliation.
This is believed to be the last Allied plane
shot down by Japanese forces during WWII.